in our culture we've turned anxiety into
a disease or into a genetic disorder or
into some sort of illness all anxiety is
is your body trying to get your
attention it's just trying to let you
know generally speaking you haven't been
taking care of your body
um like me too much caffeine 300 400
milligrams of caffeine a day my body's
gonna start rattling after a while and
then I'm not sleeping and then so on and
so forth I'm disconnected your body's
found itself without a tribe and by the
way you can be have great work mates you
can be married and happy and you can be
profoundly and deeply alone and so it is
um when your body detects you don't have
a tribe that you are all alone or if
you're not safe if you're in an abusive
relationship you don't have autonomy you
don't get to make decisions for your
life the bank does your your boss does
things like that